salut et je vais vous raconter comment
on a tourné un film d'une heure et demie
dans paris à la sortie du confinement en
un seul plan sans jamais couper la
caméra et masi c'est un soir de juin
dernier dans paris qui se réveille tel
pouvoir d'écouté les discussions des
gens qui se croisent dans la rue ils
disent qu'ils ont vécu je pensais
ressenti pleurer et mais issue à la
surface de cette terre et aurélie chaque
petite histoire dans la ville pour
raconter notre époque
alors que le cinéma est à l'arrêt nous
on n'a jamais vu autant de possibilités
de faire des films avec la pandémie il a
dû changer rapidement autour de nous
mais nous on s'est sentis de prendre le
temps c'est un bac à sable que c'est
années 2020 quoi ça c'est un super faire
un jeu comme maintenant mais dillmann a
d'une certaine manière ce jeu je nie pas
ce qui ce passe bien au contraire mais
je suis justement faut que l'on fasse
une force encore une fois comme on
n'avait pas du tout mais pas du tout le
budget d'un long métrage traditionnel on
avait l'envié on était sûr qu'avec une
équipe des terres est un langage commun
on pouvait y arriver alors on a tous
basés sur l' écoute la confiance chaque
rôle est déterminant pour la réussite
d'un plan séquence et plans séquences
donc le principe c'est que la caméra
s'arrête jamais on commence à ont
commencé le soir à 20 heures au
finisseur 21h30 donc ça a duré une heure
et demie et la caméra ne s'arrête pas
donc on peut pas reprendre par refaire
on peut pas couper si jamais eu le
moindre problème le film s'arrête et on
ne peut pas l'exploiter donc on s'est
dit on va faire six tentatives
du lundi au vendredi donc tous les soirs
on se retrouvait à telle heure à 18
heures on se motive à aller vers les
autres
on répétait ses envies péter mais
surtout on avait répété pendant le mois
précédent donc mais chaque scène
séparément et c'est un peu comme un jeu
de piste un vrai pain c'est qu'en sursis
qu'il
à pied en vélo en métro en scooter ton
et sans filet de sécurité dans la rue au
milieu de la foule et de la circulation
un dispositif technique ultra léger et
une organisation millimétrée pour se
fondre dans la ville
[Musique]
jean
certes ya pas beaucoup de deux renois
rebeu asiat enfin la blanche
mélanger ensemble dans le même verre
puis il y en a quelques-uns bien sûr et
tout bien évidemment mais c'est hyper
rare et nous qu'on voulait tellement
raconté la vie notre époque
enfin moi dans ma vie voilà je suis déçu
suis entouré de deux du monde du monde
entier quoi faire surtout à paris quand
tu as et c'est ça qui est trop bien
comme ça que j'aime et du coup pour
raconter notre époque mais obligé de
rassembler dans un film des noirs des
blancs des jaunes et des bleus des verts
tu vois obligé quoi sinon c'est sinon ça
pourrait pas raconté l'époque on a
choisi d'appeler zoofilms années 20
parce qu'on est en train de basculer
d'une époque à une autre
c'est maintenant que tout est à
réinventer on est en 2020 maintenant
qu'on peut choisir à quoi vont
ressembler nos années 20 et mes chansons
toujours du monde tu veux produire
[Musique]
on vit une époque vraiment particulière
il ya une urgence à essayer des choses à
croire que c'est possible